my kids had a really busy weekend working with their dad
so we needed a chill Monday
it's really cloudy outside which makes me tired and puts me in a fight
so when Madison asked to make clothes for her Barbies
I said why the heck not why not start our Monday with a low stress activity
if you've ever done sewing crafts with an 8 year old
you know I'm totally kidding
there is nothing low stress about a child using a sewing machine
but she did it failed
and Learned from it
so I will say it was good lessons to learn on a Monday morning
as for our actual lessons
we can have a pretty low math Learned the N k
constant team and I've been teaching these as word family
we used the all about reading word cards and sorted them into the word fam
and Madison kinda just did a Hodge podge of thing
she reviewed the contractions we Learned last week
and did a few pages of a grammar and spelling workbook that we just
she doesn't love doing workbooks
but I wanna see if it helps her reading fluency
at this point I'm trying any and all of the things
but she does really enjoy these Little Lions books and that is a win